- On this episode we have
visitors from both sides.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
this is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- 231?
- [Andy] Yes.
- Good.
Ready?
- Are you nervous?
- Very.
- You're nervous?
- Yeah.
- Why you nervous?
- I always get nervous.
- I like that.
- I'm super not nervous.
(laughter)
- [DRock] Alright, ready?
And, action.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 231 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
And it is a ridiculous show.
This is a ridiculous show.
There's a hodgepodge
of things going on.
There are so many stories here
and we finally got in a show.
I know I've been traveling a
bunch and we haven't gotten one
in so I'm glad we're doing that.
So why don't we do this?
Jake, why don't
we start with you.
Why don't you give a
little two to three seconds,
I know everybody under 35 is
gonna know exactly who you are
but that's a 57-year-olds.
- Oh, no way.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely, they exist.
Yeah, they're out there.
Why don't you tell everybody
two, three minutes
about your career?
This is a very interesting guy.
I invested in his company.
I've known his family for a
little while now but he's an
absolute blueprint to the future
and so I'm excited about
you being on the show.
- Thank you, man,
I appreciate that.
- Give 'em two cents.
- Yeah, what's up, guys?
I'm Jake Paul.
I'm a social media creator,
I'm an actor and I'm also an
entrepreneur so kind of
the three trifecta.
From Cleveland, Ohio moved
out to Los Angeles to pursue
entertainment that led to a
multitude of other things on a
Disney Channel show.
Have 17 million followers now.
Run a company called Teamdom
which has different divisions
which some of you might
of heard of Team 10.
That's really--
- How's it going?
- the summary.
- How old are you?
- I'm 19.
(laughter)
- Yep. That fuckin' hurt.
Alright, we'll get
back to that in a minute.
Now, why don't you guys tell the
Vayner Nation why you're here
and a little bit
about yourselves.
- Okay, so I'll
say why we're here.
You can say about Winbox.
- Okay.
- Basically in March we went
to London and we were at the
VaynerMedia book
launch, the #AskGaryVee book.
And we ended up
winning a competition.
We were the only guys with a
chocolate bar left, here it is.
- Vayner Chocs.
So this was how you entered
into the raffle and this was the
winning Vayner Choc.
- Is that it?
- Which (inaudible)
to hand him one.
- I love it.
- 560 is our lucky number.
- Right. There was
a number on it.
- Yeah.
- All these had numbers and
I got a little Oprah'd out and
started giving
away random prizes.
- Yeah.
- What was the
prize right before you?
Do you know?
- Was it to win a trip
to see the Jets with you?
- I don't know.
- I think it might have been
to meet you in London as well.
- Got it.
But you guys won the trip
to the US to be on the show.
- Yeah.
- And that was you winning.
- Yes.
- Were you excited?
- So excited.
My legs were shaking.
It's all a blur.
- So you guys are playing
India's role today and
you're asking the questions.
- Yeah.
- And tell everybody a
little bit about your thing.
- I'm the managing
director of Winbox.
It started about three years ago
and then Helen joined the team
about six months ago.
And we're a specialty marketing
company so we handle
newsletter, email campaigns and
automation for
different businesses.
We're a small team so
there's three of us.
So Heidi's back at the office.
(crosstalk)
But we're growing
quickly and hoping to catch up
with VaynerMedia in the email
marketing world in the future.
And we've only got 3,000
followers so if you can help us
catch up with Jake.
(laughter)
- Awesome, alright, I think
this is an appropriate
time to getting into the show.
So what is the first question?
- Okay, so the
first question is--
- [Voiceover] Bee asks, "How
safe would you play it when
"faced with the decision to
"quit your daytime job
to be an entrepreneur?"
- So Jake, you're
such a young guy.
You didn't go down the
route, did you ever have a job?
Maybe when you were 14.
- I had my own
landscaping company.
- So you were
entrepreneur from the get.
- Yeah.
- There was no I'm gonna work at
Fat Burger in Cleveland, Ohio.
- No.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if they have
Fat Burgers in Cleveland, Ohio
it was just first company.
Nonetheless, so did you
just, were your parents or
grandparents or anybody in
your family entrepreneurs?
- Not really, no.
My uncle was probably the
biggest entrepreneur but didn't
spend a ton of time with him.
Kinda just had the
natural hustle for it I guess.
My dad was like, "Yo, you
shouldn't get a regular job
"because you're not
gonna learn anything.
"If you have a
landscaping company
"you're gonna learn
how to negotiate."
- So your dad was
really pushing for it?
- Yeah.
He's was like, "You're gonna
learn how to set the prices,"--
- Yep.
- "get customers, get
recurring business."
You know?
- Yeah.
You know, look anything
that keeps you up at night is
something that
should be addressed.
And so if it's really keeping
you up at night, like you're not
sleeping, you're stressed,
you're thinking I'm gonna have
regret my whole life,
I would take it very serious and
I would play it not safe at all.
If you're kinda full of shit,
and once in a while you think
about it, and once in a blue
moon you think about it, well
then I would play it safe.
The punchline is this way too
many people are
playing it half pregnant.
You either do it or you don't.
There is no in-between and
that's the bottom line
when it comes to this.
This is binary.
You know I talk about
entrepreneurial tendencies
a ton and that's fine.
Who am I to judge just
'cause I love entrepreneurship?
You do you but this question is
silly because you don't need to
ask a question on a show
like this because if you really
couldn't breathe you wouldn't be
doing it and you wouldn't even
be worried about
my opinion on it.
Cool, let's move on.
- [Voiceover] Lucas asks, "When
did Jake know his following on
"Vine started to go big and
"what were 3 mistakes he
made during the climb?"
- So for a lot of you,
Jake and his brother
were big breakout stars on Vine.
Probably in that group of 40
to 50, 60 that really hit,
they had higher ranks but
I'm just trying to give you a
sense of like how many Vine
celebrities really popped.
When did you start, when did you
know that there was something
going on and what were a
couple mistakes that you made?
- Yeah, yeah, so it kind of
all started with on video and we
both grew 5,000
followers so that--
- Both of you?
- Yeah.
And that was like
the start of it.
Where we were like,
"Oh my gosh, we got followers.
"This is the greatest thing."
But then from then on, we just
like took that viral kind of
recipe of creating a video and
replicated it and that's when we
were gaining 5,000--
- Were you doing a lot of
collaborations to get awareness?
- No, 'cause we were in Ohio.
- Right.
- And so we're in Ohio--
- Well, what's her name's there.
- Amy?
- Yeah. She's awesome.
- Yeah.
- Remember?
- We just couldn't but yeah--
- Just like it's
far to drive in Ohio.
- Yeah.
- Driving 30 minutes is
like you don't do that.
Like a 10 minute drive is far.
- Interesting. Really?
I would've thought in Ohio
that it would be the reverse.
I feel like in New York
one block's like whoa.
But in Jersey I used to
drive like 40 minutes
just to my friend's house.
- Yeah, that's not how it is.
- Wow, Ohio's gangster.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- So what about
mistakes, real quick on that.
- Yeah, mistakes,
super important.
I think some of them is I wasn't
creating content consistently.
I didn't realize how
important that was.
- Huge.
- And then I also wasn't always
cross promoting my
different social.
So my Vine got to 5 million
followers and I would never
promote my Instagram.
- Right.
- Then Instagram is
now bigger than Vine.
- Yeah, sure.
- And so I wish I would have
done that the whole entire way.
- Let me do a recall to my
early days of influencer.
I actually struggled to talk
about my mistakes, it's like one
of the weird things about me.
It's probably a very flawed
thing but I actually, as you
were talking
reminded myself of one.
No question in '06, '07 when
I was a YouTube wine thing that
was happening, I made the
mistake of even though I knew
YouTube was gonna be huge,
Viddler came along and offered
me equity in their company to
move my show on their platform
and I took the better business
deal and I gave up the exposure.
I've only done that once 'cause
I always value exposure
over everything.
I do it all the time.
It's always long
term versus short term.
It was such a big deal and
I love and Rob and Colin,
I love Viddler and, by the way,
it had technology
where you could tag
videos and I needed that 'cause
I was making 30 minute videos
back when everybody was
making five second videos so
made sense but I, no question,
as much as I want to finagle it,
I took a short term upside of a
business deal over the long-term
value of the awareness and the
branding so that something,
you know, that battle of
short and long term is huge.
Next.
- [Voiceover] Jared asks, "Gary,
I've recently started an apparel
"company called
Rare People Apparel.
"Should I document the build up
of the business via Instagram
"and Facebook including the
behind the scenes stuff or keep
"it more professional
on the business page?"
- So the question is
I've been talking a lot about
documenting versus creating,--
- I watch you, Gary.
(group laughter)
I know.
- I love you.
So what do you think?
You think what he just said from
your opinion should the business
page be about the business
and then, what's his name?
- Jared.
- On his Jared page he's doing
kind of the vlogging and this
stuff or do you think the
business page he should consider
the vlogging there?
- What's the company called?
- It's a clothing
apparels company.
- [Helen] It's called
Rare People Apparel.
- I feel like the documenting of
it would be really cool if it
was about the grind of creating.
If the t-shirt company was
called Grind or something like
that and then he was
documenting how to grow that.
I don't know.
- For my answer on this,
I think it doesn't matter.
I think of this
similar to names.
It's ironic you used the name.
I don't think a
name means anything.
I think people make names.
Google and Facebook and Nike
meant nothing to anybody before
they were executed.
So to me, whether you do it on
your personal page or on the
business page, there's
some variable differences.
Coverage will be different.
Different things will happen but
really net-net score at the end
of the day, it won't matter.
People ask me if you build
GaryVee brand does that help
Vayner and this that
and the other thing.
Net-net it's the
steak not the sizzle.
If you get people watching in
either direction, the amount
that people actually pay
attention to that little logo
especially when it's a business,
actually deteriorates over time.
They're looking at the content
and so either plan will work for
you and I think you should spend
less time crippled by which one
and just start doing yesterday.
- [Marc] Next question is
from Vincent Errichetti.
- [Voiceover] Vincent asks, "How
do you explain to a potential
"client or partner the
importance of social media
"specifically Facebook when they
personally feel they failed
"executing in that medium and
don't believe that it worth
"the time and
money investment?"
- Have you had to have a
conversation business wise where
somebody paid to make it to your
world, an influencer where it
didn't work out for them but you
were trying to convince them to
work for you or who you rep
or things of that nature?
- Wait, say that again.
- So the question that
they're asking which is always
interesting 'cause it's actually
a very fascinating question
which is hey how do you convince
somebody to invest in Facebook
if you really believe in it when
they come back to you and say
will I've already done
Facebook and it didn't work.
- Ah. Gotcha.
- 'Cause that happens
to me all the time.
I'll answer it while you think,
I just would love your story.
I always say well listen,
what's the ROI of a basketball?
I'm gonna go
Cleveland, Ohio here.
For me, nothing, for LeBron,
a billion and the reason I use
that analogy is just 'cause you
tried Facebook doesn't
mean you did it well.
Like there's a lot of
influencers that have a lot of
followers like you do
that I know are a bad buy--
- Yeah.
- and then I know you and a
small group are good buy because
of what you do
with your attention.
- It's the content.
- 100%.
- It's the content, the
message, do you align.
Does your brand
align with that brand?
- Have you ever had to sell
somebody on doing something with
an influencer or yourself that
said to you guys well I've done
influencer marketing
before and it hasn't worked?
Has that come up yet?
- Yeah, all the time.
- And?
- You just have to--
- Punch them in the face?
- Yeah, either punch them in
the face or explain to them why
you're different--
- Theoretically.
- than that person.
- Right.
- Which is hard.
You're fighting a lost battle.
- You know it's funny,
we get to recall the name,
execution is the variable.
Again, a name.
You might think you have
the greatest name ever.
But if you suck and your
business sucks, you lost.
Here's the
punchline for everybody.
Facebook works.
Facebook advertising works.
One of my favorite quotes is
everything works,
not everything works for you.
Like it works.
That's it.
It's been documented time and
time again that it works, so
does television, so
does a lot of things.
Google search, influencer
marketing, it all works but are
you good enough to execute
it for what you're trying to
accomplish for the money
that you're allocating?
Influencer marketing works.
If you're company needs to sell
80,000 pairs of shoes that Jake
would promote and to make back
the money that you gave him and
that's how you're thinking about
your business and he only sold
17,000 in his promotion for you,
maybe that didn't work for you
in the short term.
Maybe those 17,000 pairs of
sneakers actually got talked
about by other people and
eventually you sold 97,000.
This all comes down to basic
theme of short and
long term strategy.
It was brought up
already in the show.
That's where you have
to weigh out things.
But the thought that somebody
back to really answering his
question directly, Vincent's,
ironically, I think Jake in his
way absolutely answers it
correctly which is people tell
me everything
doesn't work that we do.
- [Jake] Yeah.
- But we still built $100
million company on it because
everything that
we do also works.
The variable is the execution.
The creative, you know, the
media planning, the production,
like there's a
million variables.
The timing.
What time you post
has a variable impact.
Have you guys ever, as you were
going through it and learning
the game, did you realize that
hashtags or what time you would
post or when or when
things were trending.
- Oh, every little thing. Yeah.
- You have to understand this,
I know that they
had to live that.
When you become an expert in
your domain everybody thinks
that they're gonna be Jake.
Well, I'm gonna
make funny videos.
Everybody thinks they're
gonna be an influencer until
they realize that A,
you have to have talent,
B, you have to be a
practitioner and understand
all the things that go into it.
DRock, everybody's
got a DRock now.
You're gonna become a verb or
an adjective or a fucking noun,
I don't know.
My grammar is not that strong.
But everybody's
got a DRock, cool.
Great, so we're all gonna be
walking around in four years and
everybody's gonna have somebody
following them and filming
Mazel Tov but not
everybody's interesting and
has something to fucking say.
- Yeah.
- Sorry Tyler, that's
just the way it is.
- I'll also say, to answer his
question, I just ask people if
they have a TV in their pocket.
You have Facebook
in your pocket.
- 100%.
- You have a TV in your pocket.
Cool. Is that it?
Oh, Jake gets a question.
- Yeah, wait, I forget it.
- Make up something then.
- No, it's a good
question though.
Oh, it's like how
do you separate--
- Is this something you
actually gave a shit about?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Ok, go ahead.
- How do you separate
business and personal life?
Do you put your
phone down completely?
Do you--
- Are you worried about all the
dating life opportunities you
have in front of you?
- No.
- Okay. Just curious.
(group laughter)
- I just find it hard,
especially because--
- To turn off?
- Exactly, to turn off.
- Do you want to turn off?
- Yeah. Sometimes.
- Okay. And do you?
- No.
'Cause I feel like I have to,
I went on an off-roading trip
with my dad, I was like
in this beautiful area.
I don't have have service but
I should still film this and
Snapchat it.
- Interesting.
- Post it to Twitter.
- You feel a
pressure to execute.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean look
I think there's an evolution.
First of all, when you're 19,
when you're at three people,
you're on fire.
It's so early,
you want it so bad.
You want it so bad.
And by the way, now I'm the old
guy in this thing, at 40 I still
want it so bad mainly
because my ambition is so high.
I think it's a very
personal question.
You know, for me the reality is
a lot of these things we talk
about them in theory.
We answer questions,
we got thoughts but
they're very detailed.
There's always a nuance in
everybody's life that
does it's thing.
I just do what I want to do and
I never question
myself or my actions.
I think too many people cripple
some ideological
thing on themselves.
I should turn off here
because it's so beautiful.
Fuck this beautiful place.
Document it.
- [Jake] Yeah.
- Do you know what I mean?
I don't do that to myself.
I don't let anybody and most
importantly even my own points
of view on what I should do
dictate how I feel about myself.
I just do and then think about
it after the fact instead of
prior which has been a very,
very, very substantial switch
that I have that has made
me very happy to be honest.
I'm not judging myself.
I love myself.
I love that picture, you know
that picture with the Pope and
everybody's taking a picture
and there's that one old lady.
It's like a very famous picture.
Do you know about this?
Thank you.
And everyone's like,
"Oh, she really captured it."
There's a picture for everybody
who's watching, actually throw
it up here in the edit.
There's a picture, here it is.
(bell dings)
Where everybody heralded
this lovely old lady, right?
She actually captured the moment
while everybody else looked at
the Pope through their phone.
I don't believe that.
I actually feel bad
for that old lady.
I believe that she's
already forgotten it.
- Yes.
- Right, that everybody else
actually has it documented and
has a nice asset and I think we
are absolutely going through a
very weird time where we
demonize technology and we
idolize old and true things
'cause people hate change.
We, and I'm about to get really
pissed here 'cause
this blows my mind,
I'll be there in a minute.
We, close it, we,
we have
somehow put writing
a letter on a pedestal.
That if I write you a letter,
that this is one of the great
things that I can do in society.
Like oh my God,
you're such a lovely person.
You wrote me a letter.
You're so special.
Yet, when we text someone we
don't view that as special.
We view that as bad.
We should be
talking to each other.
What we've done is we've put a
piece of paper and a pen on a
pedestal and we've demonized
a phone but neither matters
because they're
just the mediums,
it's the message
inside that matters.
You want to say something
sweet and phenomenal to me,
I don't give a shit if you do it
through a pen and paper or
via text in emojis, it's the
intent behind the love not the
fucking medium, assholes.
- I love you, Gary.
(laughter)
- I mean, seriously.
- I love you so much.
- Right? That is fascinating.
So yes, great, you can put
grandma on a pedestal and say
she actually is the purest
form, things are changing.
Either get on board or don't.
(group laughter)
Question of the day,
I'll let you ask it.
- This is me watching
your videos at home--
- Just in real life?
Question of the day, ask
the question of the day.
Any question you want,
what do you want the
Vayner Nation to answer.
- Can we do a request?
- Sure.
- Okay.
- That was pretty
ballsy, I like it.
Good job, go ahead.
- We want to do a request
for anyone who receives
spammy emails--
- Oh, you're not going with a
request, you're going with a
sales pitch.
Even more ballsy, go ahead.
- Okay, spammy sales emails that
just bring them no value,
we want them to email them and
say get in touch
with Winbox so
we can do email
marketing better.
- Wow. You really
went there, huh?
I'm impressed.
Take control of your moment.
You came from the UK
might as well do it.
Any final parts for you?
- No, I would say I think one
of the questions I saw in the
comments was like they
always watch these videos and
then no one executes.
And I would say actually
take this information and
run with with the wind.
You know?
- I mean you've done that, like
I've, you know, I'm an investor
and believer in you and your,
I mean I invested in your
company because I believe in
you so much
because you're right,
most people don't execute and
you have and so
I appreciate that.
And at 19 I love it, impressive.
Guys, thank you for coming.
I hope your trip to
New York is awesome.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)